from his time at Stanford to a
congressional run Ben Savage has been
busy even if he doesn't Grace our TV
screens as much these days so what is
the formerly super famous young actor up
to now
Corey Matthews finally met the world
when Boy Meets World wrapped up in 2000
and lead actor Ben Savage was ready to
move on he told Rolling Stone I was 19
at the time and had been on the show for
seven years I was really focused on
going to college and that he did Savage
enrolled at the prestigious Stanford
University and he mostly retreated from
Show Business only appearing in one
major role over the next six years in
2002's swimming Upstream at Stanford
Savage surprisingly didn't major in
theater film Communications or any other
kind of Arts or entertainment based
discipline instead he pursued a degree
in political science with a special
interest in government and structure as
many high achieving college students do
Savage also supplemented his studies of
how the government works with the kind
of prestigious high-profile internship
that most any political science major
would want he worked in the Washington
DC Office of the late Pennsylvania
Senator Arlen Spector he told Rolling
Stone getting an internship in DC is
really all about Connections I thought
it would be a fun experience
it's not that Ben Savage has completely
disappeared from Hollywood it's just
that he's not the out and out star of a
popular situation comedy anymore he does
however stay in the world of Show
Business by playing the episodic TV
guest star of the week game not only
does that kind of work pay the bills it
also gives an actor a chance to put his
performance skills to the test
potentially playing a wildly different
character with every new gig Savage has
really mixed it up too he played a nerdy
military engineer on Chuck a possible
murderer on without a trace a nasty
blogger on the kitcom shake it up a
sketchy lottery winner on Bones and as
the younger version of Mandy patinkin's
character on a flashback episode of
Criminal Minds it's never been more
important to catch a guy like this if
you're over the age of say 20 you're
probably most familiar with Ben Savage
for his role as Corey Matthews on Boy
Meets World if you're under the age of
20 you know him from reruns of Boy Meets
World that have aired on the Disney
Channel for the past 20 years the show
proved so popular that it led to the
network sequel series called Girl Meets
World a brief synopsis Corey and his Boy
Meets World girlfriend Topanga are now
adults in their 30s and the parents of a
tween named Riley it turns out that
going back to the role that made him
famous in the first place is just what
Savage needed Girl Meets World ran for
72 highly rated episodes the Disney
Channel ended the series in 2017 before
it had a chance to get stale
somewhere in between a guest star gig
and being a full-fledged series regular
is the casting status known as recurring
role in which a character Pops in every
few episodes or a few consecutive
installments as part of a plot Arc after
the demise of Girl Meets World in 2017
Savage signed up for a stint on a
semi-obscure sitcom called Still The
King it starred Billy Ray Cyrus as
Vernon Vernon a scandal prone one-hit
wonder who can't find any traction in
the music industry and winds up becoming
a drunk driving Elvis impersonator
turned Church handyman on parole it was
in short the complete opposite of Boy
Meets World and yet it attracted Ben
Savage who over the course of four
episodes played Jean a federal agent and
Master of Disguise unfortunately for
Savage CMT canceled Still The King in
late 2017. I'm a porta potty baby during
the relative obscurity between when Boy
Meets World went off the air in 2000 and
when Girl Meets World debuted on the
Disney Channel in 2014 Savage made one
notable attempt to return to TV as the
star of a Primetime show in 2007 Savage
headlined a lawyer sitcom called making
it legal created by Freaks and Geeks
writer Jeff Juda the series would have
concerned two attorneys competing for an
open partner slot at their Chicago firm
Savage stayed in his wheelhouse playing
a neurotic nervous and eager to please
young lawyer the cast also included
Scott wolf Ashley Williams and Jeffrey
Arendt making it legal could have been
Savage's big comeback and it could have
represented a complete break with his
kid stuff past but unfortunately the
pilot didn't get picked up for a full
series run
Savage has tried to get a movie career
going with a variety of roles in an
array of low budget independently
produced films while they might have
earned solid reviews and enjoyed modest
audiences at festivals and on home video
they were small movies in every way as
opposed to Big blockbuster hits or major
award winners they didn't do much to
increase Savage's reach among the
interesting but obscure projects in
which Savage starred are the addiction
family drama the caterpillars kimono the
Opposites Attract romantic comedy Girl
Meets Boy the teen cancer tearjerker
swimming upstream and Palo Alto
California a dramedy about four friends
reuniting in their Hometown on the first
Thanksgiving of their college Years
Ben Savage has a lot in common with his
older brother Fred Savage both got their
start as kid actors and are best known
for long-running ABC sitcoms that became
cultural touchstones then for Boy Meets
World and Fred for The Wonder Years
they've also both moved behind the
camera and behind the scenes as they
aged choosing to act less but opting to
direct and produce Fred Savage has
produced a few comedy shows such as
party down and Garfunkel and Oates and
he's directed dozens of half hour
episodes for shows like the Goldbergs
and It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
Ben Savage has once again followed his
older brother into the family business
Savage served as a co-producer for more
than four dozen episodes of Girl Meets
World and he also took the director's
chair for 10 episodes of the hit Disney
Channel Revival family game night
my favorite night of the month
a lot of actors who dominated TV in the
1990s by virtue of starring on a heavily
watched Network sitcom didn't actually
disappear from pop culture or quit
acting they just moved into a niche
where their services are appreciated and
their mere presence provides comfort and
Nostalgia several former child stars and
teen actors from the 1990s and early
2000s nowadays make a decent living and
enjoy sizable followings by starring in
movies made specifically for cable TV
stations this includes Savage in 2020
Savage headlined Love lights Hanukkah
it's one of the Hallmark Channel's many
holiday romance movies and one of the
few with a non-christmas theme two years
later Savage broke out of his easy going
and comedic wheelhouse with the lifetime
original girl in the shed the kidnapping
of Abby Hernandez in the True Crime
docudrama Savage portrayed real-life
kidnapper Nathaniel Kibby my friends
will kill your entire family
Ben Savage is a seasoned veteran of
multiple television shows over the
decades and so is Mandy Patinkin as such
Savage now fills a very specific Niche
for TV producers he's the guy to call
when a script calls for a younger
version of a batinkin character in a
flashback sequence in the second to last
episode of Criminal Minds which aired in
2020 Savage played Jason Gideon but
dinkin's character from the series in
some scenes said in the distant past
been just a couple of months later
Savage guest art on homeland as the
younger past version of Saul Berenson
who was played in the present day of the
series by Mandy Patinkin Homeland
co-creator Alex Gonza told TV line there
was some talk of trying to make Mandy
who is 67 in real life looked like he
was in his late 20s but we did some
tests and it just wasn't believable
after dismissing the idea of hiring one
of patinkin's real-life Sons gansa
learned that Savage had played a younger
version of a Patinkin character on
Criminal Minds and reached out gansa
said of the decision he just Bears such
an uncanny resemblance to Mandy
not in the public eye as much as he once
was actor Ben Savage has valued his
privacy and his time out of the
spotlight choosing to cultivate personal
relationships with that de facto Frida
he embraced living a life not under
constant scrutiny and developed a
romantic relationship that he kept
virtually secret for four years
according to people Savage quietly began
dating Tessa angermyer in 2018 about
four years later around Christmas 2022
the couple announced their engagement in
an Instagram photo the photo was posted
on Savage's account as anger Meyer has
her account on private they'd only
occasionally appeared in public together
but anger Meyer was present for Savage's
campaign events while running for West
Hollywood city council in 2022 in a
written statement Savage's
representative told people they are both
very grateful in enjoying this exciting
time with their families and friends Ben
Savage isn't as exceptionally busy as he
once was with his acting career which
gives him the time and energy to pursue
other passions in his college days
Savage served as an intern in the
Washington DC office of Pennsylvania
Senator Arlen Spector and decade later
in 2022 he ran for office himself Savage
vied for a seat on the city council in
West Hollywood California where he lived
for nearly two decades according to his
campaign website when all the votes were
tallied Savage didn't win one of the
open seats on the board according to the
Los Angeles County Registrar recorder
Savage finished in sixth place out of 12
candidates garnering 6.32 of all ballots
cast undeterred months later Savage
officially set his sights on a higher
federal office in January 2023 Savage
announced that he'd filed with the
federal elections commission to run as a
democrat in California's 30th house
district in the U.S House of
Representatives a seat set to be vacated
when representative Adam Schiff leaves
to run in a U.S Senate election
[Music]
thank you